here's a few questions which are using
the skills of in developing your over
the last couple weeks okay so you can
see we've gone away from just right
here's an angle and here's a rapier just
give me the number out we're going in
the opposite direction which is a bit
trickier because there's more than one
answer okay so for instance number one
where come in fixing for number one and
they're all in this standard domain here
I'm going to do this way now last time I
we're just doing our practice and review
my go-to tool of choice was to go to the
quadrants all stations to central and to
use that okay um this morning might go
to because I think it's really important
that you master both it's so useful is
I'm going to go straight to the graph
okay so when I draw this guy do you
remember how i did a rough really fast
version of 10 here's my even faster
version okay one two three there you go
so I've got the rough idea now where it
is on where it is negative one on this
graph well it's going to be below the
axis isn't it and I draw my horizontal
life through okay some expect the
solution here at a solution here right
so to know what my result is going to be
I think about okay 10 and sequels good
morning negative 1 negative 1 now
remember being at the quadrants is just
one way to solve it and the graph is
another way right what a handy things
about the graph is you can actually
include decided it helps you right so if
you have your calculator there if you
don't get it out if 10 x equals negative
1 right we're used to saying from this
I'm going to reach my calculator and
turn this around and use tan inverse
right with that minus 1 then now if I
put in negative 1 okay which is what i
have on the right hand side the
calculator will helpfully give me an
answer but you just have to be careful
with it and see how you can use the
center to find it it's a we work so when
you do 10 inverse of negative 1
interestingly it gives you negative 45
negative 45 when we're doing signing
cause
or whenever it is sine inverse or cause
adverse it would give you some positive
angle but this one's giving me a
negative why is it doing that where is
where is negative 45 or on my diagram I
haven't actually drawn it right this is
not to 360 naught 2 360 negative 45
would be over here negative 45 degrees
okay this is an answer like if i put in
10 and negative 45 i'll get negative 1
but it's not any inside in this range
that i'm interested in this domain i
should say okay so if that's an answer
and i know that tan repeats every how
often I'm integrate 180 degrees right
take up to this year top I'm just gonna
have to add 180 right and to get to the
third or the second is up i'm going to
add 180 again okay so all i need to say
using the calculator and using my graph
is i can say from the ground right I'm
going to have my two answers which are
negative 45 plus 180 1.5 okay all plus
180 again which is 315 I think ok now if
you wanted to try this out the other way
you do your quadrants you'd say okay I
want to tend to be negative Thank
negative sir which quadrants am I in 1 2
3 4 which ones do I choose I choose
second and fourth right because you can
see everything is positive here and 10
is positive here so I want those I want
the other ones right this is your
segment second quadrant angle 135 will
be over here and this is your fourth
question table 3 15 will be over here
really quickly to Tyler's x equals are
half ok so again it's to really really
quick sketchy people say are cracking I
don't like using as a technique because
it takes so long did anyone count I was
like all about five seconds okay
remember this is different to the
question being graph the question is
solved but i'm using a graph right so
doesn't have to be beautiful just ask
you good enough to solve your question
when i put in a half I know that this is
one so a half must be kind of well half
the way up so draw my line through
that's why I can see there's a first
quadrant angle here in a fourth quadrant
angle here cos x equals half that's an
exact value has anyone learnt it by now
is it all memorized it's 60 degrees very
good so I can say that's got to be the
first one and the fourth quadrant one is
60 degrees that way so it must be 300
bama recordings reply lastly in review
question 3 this is what we're doing last
Thursday so if you missed that lesson
this money raised an eyebrow for you
we're going to use this sine rule the
side wall in this question and the
result we proved was a on sign a equals
B on sine B which is also if you wanted
to you can have the third side and the
third angle there okay we only have two
pairs here so I don't actually need this
pilot once I have this Idol down I'm
just feeling in just feeling you right
so here's the one I want that's what I'm
laughter so I tend to put that first so
I have to do a minimum of every region I
look at the angle that's opposite it so
that's sign
you seven and then I light up the other
care so I've got 44 on side 31 okay from
there what do i do need to do to get X
on its own to make extra subject yeah
good yeah i'm going to multiply this guy
crush right so i'm going to get into my
calculator i'm going to 44 side 57 on
sine theta wanna someone already
calculated for me to one decimal place
71.6 ok now just before we pause and
leave this question does the answer
makes sense does it look about right
remember the whole point of the same
rule is to say if you've got a small
angle there should be a small side and
if there's a bigger anymore there ought
to be a bigger side it checks out looks
perfect to me and it's not like 7000 or
something that would be ridiculous with
the unit they're doing okay perfect